you
[Music]
this morning on the dish a pioneer and
all things smoked pickled and preserved
will Horowitz was born into a family
with a food heritage one grandmother was
a classically trained chef his other
grandparents owned a traditional Jewish
deli and he studied everything from
Buddhism to herbalism it's a wilderness
survival before attending cooking school
in 2012 he and a sister Julie opened
ducks eatery here in New York three
years later came Harry and Ida's meat
and supply of vintage deli and food
provision shop and now he's the author
of a new book salt smoked I'm
homesteading and heritage techniques for
the modern kitchen will horowitz good
morning and welcome to the - good
morning it's a pleasure to be here what
do we have in front of us who we try
recite this the best we can okay we'll
guys start with dessert because it's
closest to me there it is so we have
some duck fat charred blueberries with
some whipped honey and fresh lavender we
have some cured and smoked carrots with
a little watercress sauce some smoked
tomahawk steaks I've already seen some
hands hands in that black trumpets and
currants and then this is our famous
here watermelon that that feeder is
doing it right it's pretty wild and next
to that I think we have a little bit of
cured and preserved mussels with house
whip butter and sourdough and we have a
honeysuckle mezcal a lemon fizz sweet
your background is just fascinating I
mean just your your grandparents your a
ping-pong champion from whatever give me
some sense of what it was like growing
up that created who we know now today I
have no idea in the suburbs of New York
in White Plains New York and definitely
got into my share of trouble as a kid
like pretty much every chef that's
probably behind the show and I end up in
Colorado going to school out there for
writing and and permaculture and
Buddhism and so really and that's where
the smoking start really I started
studying off-the-grid living and
primitive survival in school and so this
is kind of a reflection of that we
same courses just before the show every
the smoke can we just asked about the
smoke watermelon yeah cause it's so fun
I mean it's so cool to look at and the
way you slice it too
yeah yeah I mean we really and you know
I say for us coming from so much smoked
meat and smoked fish hmm all these
heritage techniques we want to do more
sustainable vegetarian foods and
plant-based foods because obviously
that's really big right now but we want
to do it in a way that for us was less
frankensteining you know I know that
sounds crazy but to be honest when you
have all these crazy burgers and
products that are out there they're
meant to look like they bleed for us a
smoked watermelon
we're doing the same exact thing we've
been doing for thousands of years to me
so we're doing the same processes and
that's the beauty of is that we're
keeping things whole it's it's crazy
looking because it's so different ham
but for us it's actually completely
relative and we just and the you guys
try the smoked carrots yeah no carrots
are good they're almost kind of meaty
and that's the beauty of them yeah
actually hairy and there's our other
restaurant we actually just started a
line of smoked carrot hot dogs and
celery root that slices like smoked
turkey and all these different processes
that are just the same techniques as
meat but changing the direction to
plants but sustainability is big a big
part of what you do yeah you plan on
writing more about it yeah I mean we
already have some fun stuff in the works
I'm working in right now and a
children's book hopefully on
sustainability is my next book but for
us it's all about how do we still eat
meat but do it more responsibly more of
a connection to where it's from and how
do we make plants more the star of the
show
I'm not sure how sustainable these
tomahawks are oh my god that's but they
are massive and look amazing so if we're
going to eat less meat let's at least
make it really really
Winstone's right there with it's a very
flintstone cut we're gonna have you sign
a dish and if you could have this meal
with anyone past or present will who
would it be all right so I've watched
your guys show haven't given this some
thought go ahead and right now it's
between Hemingway and Winnie the Pooh
and we go for Winnie the Pooh because I
just think he's gave me a less intense
fella with a good appetite and you'll
have some money when I sign Hemingway on
it thank you have them both because that
would be fascinating
thank you guys if you want more on will
and the dish you can head to our website
at
cBS This Morning Calm